thank you all for being here my name is
shannon rose mcauliffe i'm the manager
of the student arts programs at mit
and we're all here today to kick off the
2020 2021
15k creative arts competition we'll have
a series of
workshops a really thorough application
session with some feedback
one-on-one mentoring and lots of things
like pitch critiques
to help everybody no matter where they
are with their venture
to um enable them to succeed
so i'm really excited to kick things off
so without further ado i'm gonna
introduce
wendy smart grossman and jen gilliman
from creative reframe
hello mit hey hey we're so happy to be
here i am jen gilliman
and i am wendy schwart grossman and we
are so
honored to be with you today um here at
mit
and i want to start with a story
about the first entrepreneur i ever met
who trusted his instincts took on risk
invested in his employees and challenged
conventional wisdom
with humor and brilliance it was my
brother this summer my brother martin
was nine years old
he had a crazy successful lemonade stand
in front of our house
he made so much money it kept him in
candy bars
and comic books throughout the long
winter
and based on this early success at nine
the next summer when he turned 10
he expanded he franchised his lemonade
stands
and he had three of them around the
neighborhood that were run
by his trusted buddies and when he was
11
he branched out to the local beach and
he would sell
cans of ice cold sodas to the sunbathers
for yeah a 50 percent mic up markup per
cam
he was so successful he was shut down by
the park and rec police
because he didn't have a peddler's
license he but
he didn't just go away not my brother
man he set up his wagon
full of coolers on the far side of the
street and had his staff of middle
schoolers
fan the beach taking orders yep
martin delivered he was a brilliant
man but not in a conventional way
in fact he barely graduated from high
school because he was too
busy with the company that he started at
age 16.
he had one of these curious nimble minds
and he was hungry and he saw a hole in
the market
and the floor cleaning business that he
started grew to be the largest floor
cleaning
buffing and waxing company in southern
california called floor tech
he had a fleet of trucks and hundreds of
crew members
making him a millionaire by the time he
was 26.
there are so many ways to be creative in
starting your business
your own venture and just as many
reasons why people feel compelled
to put something new in the world for my
brother
he loved money the more the better in
fact he would iron
his dollar bills in order to fit more of
them into his wallet
to him it was a fascinating game
he also loved creating networks and
talking to people
similar to myself and giving his
employees
opportunities to change their lot in
life by
offering them real wages and i'm an
entrepreneur myself
but my bottom line isn't money i'm
motivated
by how many people i can touch and help
and organize my return on investment
is measured not only by profit but on
the social
return on investment known as the triple
bottom line
yes profit but people and planet as well
while my brother was busy making his
millions i was a political organizer
tapping into my superpower of connection
by working on presidential campaigns and
then pivoting
to nonprofits and now i am both an
educator
and co-founder with jen of a creative
consulting startup
i needed to trust what motivated me
but but enough about me enough about my
brother that what we're here for is to
talk about you
what is important here is understanding
and tacking into
what it is that motivates you where
do you have and where do you find what
jen and i have coined as
your kip your can care what do you care
about
what issue is it that interests you what
ideas do you
have and where is your passion because
the more
you understand and trust your motivation
for doing what you do the more authentic
the more connected and the more
meaningful
your work becomes and this is what the
15k
creative arts competition here at mit is
really all about
it's about giving you the tools and the
incentives you need
to start your own creative venture
we know that the best ventures are those
that solve not only real problems but
are attached
to a passion that you as the founder
holds when i moved to boston
in the mid 90s i went to a community
arts event and i met a person who
changed the course of my life
his name was sidewalk sam and he was an
artist a provocateur a visionary and the
first
creative entrepreneur i ever met if you
were living in boston in the mid 90s you
would know exactly the person that i'm
talking about
sidewalk sam was trained as an artist
and
wanted to make his living being an
artist he started out as a
kind of in a traditional way of having a
studio and
doing working with galleries but that
didn't work for him
he wanted something else so he carved
out his own unique niche
as a street artist he began using chalk
to draw
replicas of famous masterpieces on the
sidewalks throughout boston
and as his fame grew so did his client
base and corporate sponsors
the streets of boston became his canvas
in 1990 five years before i met him
the mayor of boston was trying to figure
out how to celebrate the 20th
anniversary of earth day
sidewalk sam made a proposal he said i
know
i have an idea let's shut down the
streets the me a major thoroughfare
store or drive in boston
paint it with biodegradable paint and
invite all the people of boston to come
out and draw
flowers and trees and butterflies
turning a highway
into an urban meadow when they looked at
him like he was crazy
and asked how he thought they might pay
for this he was two steps ahead of them
he had already secured dunkin donuts as
a corporate sponsor
thousands of people came out to the
streets that day
and drew pictures on stero drive
the genius of sidewalk sam was his
ability
to leverage the transformative power of
the arts
to create community in partnership with
local businesses
his sponsors achieved their strategic
business objectives while supporting
sidewalk sam
and he was able to achieve his mission
of bringing art to the people
i should mention as a bit of a
disclaimer that i spent a lot of time
with sidewalk sam over the years because
i ended up marrying his son
in the late 90s and together we
volunteered
at hundreds of events over the course of
two decades
throughout his career sidewalk sam's
events became more
and more participatory in nature as he
espoused the belief
that everyone is an artist
to him the arts weren't rarified and
only for the elite the arts were alive
and they were for all of us to share
at one festival in downtown boston i
volunteered to hand out chalk a man was
walking past and
he reluc reluctantly agreed to take a
piece of chalk and draw on the sidewalk
however when he started drawing his
whole demeanor changed
usually people draw for maybe five
minutes he ended up staying
and drawing for a full hour and when he
returned the talk to me he had tears in
his
eyes he explained to me that he worked
his whole life
in insurance and he loved to draw as a
kid and he
only that day remembered how much he
missed it
something opened up in him that day and
that was the magic of sidewalk sam
his form of entrepreneurship was to
create environments that change hearts
and minds
sidewalk sand made his living doing what
he loved which is not easy in the arts
and his return on investment was
collective joy
he changed lives by helping people
unlock their personal creativity
and he certainly influenced me because i
became an entrepreneur
working within a university to create
programs and courses for art students
so they too could find ways to unlock
their creative purpose
whether you relate more to martin the
millionaire's story
or sidewalk sam's model of the
importance of putting something
out in the world that taps into
connection
and creativity you know it really
doesn't matter
because they're both incredibly
important and they're both
equally valid there is room at the table
for all the reasons people show up and
are motivated to create and
there really is no better place to
explore this than mit
math science technology
but also arts resources like the one
that this very 15k
creative arts competition represents
through the arts
at mit programming what jen and i have
found
from working in the innovation and
entrepreneurship
spaces is the importance of this type of
crea
of cross-disciplinary thinking and that
all
starts have our and with having this all
starts with having
the diversity of ideas and the skill
sets
to get it out there so while right now
you may just have a hint of an idea
it's crucial to say it aloud and to talk
with others about it and to think
broadly
about what skills will be needed to put
this
idea that's hatching into action
taking inventory of yourself and being
incredibly honest of the skills you come
to the table with
and what it is you need that you don't
have
then finding others that share your big
goal
your big dream but come at it from
really different entry points
as this will only make your finished
project that much better
for example jen and i have crazy
different backgrounds so
jen has this incredibly rich career in
both
higher education and the arts world and
i
come from a political background as i
mentioned
but together we started a company but we
also knew that we needed even
we needed help from other folks so we
reached out
to the small business development
administration
in downtown boston and met with their
volunteer teams of lawyers and business
advisors
and then we hired a designer to get our
website
up and running and now we employ other
incredible people
who help us with the pieces that they
love and are really good at
including social media database
management and marketing
so as you're thinking about your venture
that might be brewing
in the back of your head think about
what makes
for a powerful combination
what are your superpowers and be honest
and who can help fill in the holes
with their superpowers
but um we need to get real we need to
really talk and address the elephant in
the room and unfortunately
it's more like a whole herd of elephants
we are nine days away
from the most important election in a
hundred or more years
two hundred and twenty thousand people
have died in the u.s alone
from coba 19 and over one million
have died across our shared planet
disparity between the haves and the
have-nots is
huge and unfortunately it's growing
and of course this is all playing out
with the backdrop
of a world that is on fire
other than that mrs lincoln how did you
enjoy the play
it's nutty but we're here to tell you
that there is hope and there is
inspiration
and what we are finding is that
creativity
is alive and well human beings
are programmed to be in community
to live to inspire to pivot and grow
and this provides all of us with the
incredible hope
and inspiration we all need to get
ourselves out of bed
we as a nation are turning to the arts
and to creative problem solvers as our
salve
our balm our hope
one of the projects that jen and i work
on at creative reframe
is called 100 conversations launched
in the summer of 2019 the two of us
would jump on our bikes and tool around
boston
meeting with individual inspirational
creative practitioners
artists and thought leaders in order to
help build a culture
of creativity around their shared
stories
making connections and building
community
this of course is now morphed into
socially distanced
conversations and zoom calls and we are
documenting
how these same incredible arts leaders
are pivoting
thinking broader and being in many ways
even more impactful one of these
conversations
was with the arts at mit's very own
shannon rose
who in addition to adding her brilliance
to mit
she's a singer and a co-founder of
festina
bringing gorgeous uplifting church
music to congregations across new
england
thanks to covid they have pivoted to a
unique niche
and have had thousands of hits for a
piece they have done
setting the cd cdc coveted guidelines to
liturgical music
check out the chat box for the link
in addition to fistina we've had
conversations with arts administrators
entrepreneurs muralists and musicians
and while our current situation is less
than ideal
to paraphrase toni morrison
this is precisely the time that
creatives go to work
there's no time for despair no time for
self-pity
no need for silence no room for fear
we speak we write we do language
that is how civilizations heal
for 10 years wendy and i have been
teaching courses on cultural
entrepreneurship and the creative
economy to millennials and gen z
students initially our goal was to
provide art students with basic business
skills to help them build sustainable
careers in the arts
but what we found was that students from
across the university
business computer science even
engineering
were signing up for our classes too even
if they didn't plan on going into the
creative professions
they were drawn to the class and we
wondered why
well we learned that these students
craved opportunities
to be creative and to work across
disciplines
and think of new ways that they can both
make money while doing something that
was meaningful to them
we were teaching something they were not
getting in some of their other courses
reminding us once again that arts and
creativity are really inherent
to what it means to be human
our class helps students create and
launch
ventures that reside at the intersection
of arts and culture
business and technology and social
impact
and we know that your generation has the
capacity to reimagine
better jobs of the future and what
better place
to explore this convergence of arts and
technology
than right here at mit at creative
reframe
we have a saying and it goes like this
make like an artist care like an
activist
strategize like an entrepreneur and
implement
like an organizer so as you begin your
journey
in the 15k creative arts competition we
leave you
with four key takeaways
make trust your creative
vision don't be afraid to think
differently
invite disruption find a need and think
about your unique approach
to meeting that need think about
your kip as wendy mentioned earlier your
care
idea issue passion because it is your
kip
that is your fuel it is what will help
you get through sleepless nights
rejection and the grueling work
that comes hand in hand with creating a
startup
for martin he knew exactly what people
wanted on that hot beach during the
summer
for sidewalk sam he recognized the need
for creativity
in everyday life at creative reframe
we care about integrating arts and
innovation spaces
what is your creative vision
care get other people excited and get
other people to care about your vision
find others who want to share your
passion and build your team
people are attracted to purpose and a
clear
vision the research shows that most
people
find meaning and purpose when they are
part of something bigger than themselves
so with that in mind how might your
venture consider
the triple bottom mind line people
planet
and profit by attaching yourself to
a greater purpose people are more likely
to join you
in implementing that vision whether it
was martin's team of helpers
combing that beach or sidewalk sam's
participants who
rediscovered art after many years these
are the things that you could be doing
when your kip is steeped in meaning you
can find and build
ventures that not only help other
people's lives
but also offer you deep satisfaction
strategize seek and build excellence
build operational excellence around your
idea put together a solid business model
that you feel proud of and that meets a
need
addressing not only the return on the
investment but also
the social return on investment
and finally implement use the vast
resources
that are available right here at mit and
across boston
there will be workshops and programs
designed to help you
build and amplify your adventure so you
can bring your creative vision
into the spotlight take advantage of all
of it
as you will carry these skills with you
for the rest of your life
throughout the entire process we remind
you
to remember the values of being thinking
like an artist
remember the power of improvisation
empathy
social imagination and resourcefulness
in her book the culture of possibility
arlene goldbard
writes we need to learn to see like the
most committed and skilled artists
eyes wide open taking it all in turning
away from nothing
cultivating empathy and imagination
taking risks admitting mistakes and
persevering
in essence my friends the arts and
entrepreneurship
are really not that different both rely
on storytelling to express
compelling narratives both are about
taking risks
and making mistakes and persevering
whatever your entrepreneurial journey is
and whatever story got you here today
we are here to say yes go for it
you've got this there is so much hope
and potential and opportunity at the
intersection
of arts and technology and the 15k
creative arts competition is the perfect
launching pad for you
we commend you as you set forth on your
journey and we look forward to seeing
the seeds that you plant today and see
how they grow over the course of the
months ahead
your work will help to reimagine the
jobs the products
and the services of the future
thank you for joining us and thank you
arts at mit
for inviting creative reframe to help
launch
the 15k creative arts competition
thank you both so much that was
fantastic
um also your technology is so impressive
this is the best
zoom keynote that i've seen in eight
months
for the technicians behind the kitchen
table
beautifully done everybody so that was
full of some really fantastic
insights and a lot of motivation um i'm
curious to know if anybody has any
questions for wendy and jen
or if wendy and jen have any questions
for others um
they sort of like to turn these things
upside down so we're gonna do
sort of a 360 conversation
before we take our break
well we would like to invite some of the
people here
today um to to share your creative
vision with us if we have anybody
jen and i have been working in this
field for a long time and working with
students just like all of you
to help you take these little ideas and
help them launch and we're so
curious who's out there in the zoom in
the zoom verse
to see how we can help you as you move
through
through it all any things anything
bubbling out there
i'll also comment that if you need a
little time to sort of
marinate on everything that we just
discussed our third session will also
include
sort of the opportunity for conversation
with really wonderfully established
entrepreneurs and educators
i know that we have some people in here
who are studying entrepreneurship so i'd
be curious to see
what the takeaways were or what's
excited you about this
and we're kind of open books i'll talk
about anything
yeah yeah uh
let's see i mean this was all really
motivating and i've got a question um
it can all seem sort of like scaling
everest you know
when you finally got these great ideas
and you finally got all of this energy
it's it's an awfully big uphill climb so
what are the smallest or sort of most
important steps that you would say will
help people to catalyze their success
[Music]
so what i usually do is like i it's all
about ripping off your blinders
going through the world and starting to
take being being
what i call as being awake and aware
paying attention
to you know what's working what's not
working where is there like an
interesting hole in the market
what do you like to do so it really kind
of depends
on you know sometimes you start with a
problem
sometimes you start with an idea
sometimes you start because you're
excited
and sometimes you start because you're
pissed off there's so many different
fabulous
organizations that have been popping up
that are student-led
that was because they realized that the
world was on fire and
you know who's gonna start who's gonna
you know so so i
it's really kind of paying attention to
both sides of the coin
and really it starts with that whole
inventory of you know what skills do i
have
what am i good at also paying attention
to
to you know oh i i like this
i want more of this you know what is the
this
for you anything to add
i think you i think you did a good job
covering it i think also there are
people who have these crossover
interests that are really
interesting and i think at a place like
mit
that is something that you'll see so
you'll have somebody who has this
background in engineering but they're cr
they're also really passionate about
music and so to think about like
what's happening at that intersection
and what might you bring to it that is
so
unique about you because you have these
two interests that collide
in really interesting ways so i think to
be really aware of that
um we think of the arts as something
that can just be a source of
inspiration internally but it also could
be part of your business uh
idea and and that could launch you into
a new direction
and what we love is that that whole
cross-disciplinary
mess it's there's and sometimes if we
were together in person
we would be i'll be wearing name tags
with different colored dots on them
one would be red i have an idea ask me
about it another one would be blue
saying you know i i've got a lot of cool
skills and i want to help you
so it's like in finding those other
people sometimes we do have the idea
and we don't know what to do next
sometimes we want to work with somebody
else but we don't have the idea
so that's that's that's the trick is
being able to find each other
because you don't want to do it alone
because that's like boring and lonely
and
you know these are all really boring
these are excellent points
especially about the necessity of team
building and partnership
yeah definitely and we had a question
based on that and so um thinking about
those kind of key partnerships how do
you know
um when you're ready for partnership and
how do you go about finding those kind
of key partners
you're ready for a partnership you
always want a partner don't do it alone
that's a big red flag it's
like oh i've got this great idea and i'm
going to do it all by myself and i'm
like
oh cringe cringe cringe cringe no you
always need help
um and so it's i'm saying that was the
first part it was the second
question i don't know i just got excited
about finding something to work with
well i
i really like your question theo because
i think it happens in a lot of different
ways sometimes people really unite over
a shared interest
sometimes you just have chemistry with
somebody and then you're like oh how can
we do something together so as just a
little
back story um when wendy and i first
met we uh we we had gone up we didn't
really know each other and we just went
out for a drink and we started talking
and then
like i saw i was i was asked to propose
a course and because i had such a great
conversation with wendy i was like i
want to co-teach
i bet we'd be really good co-teaching
together and so
we started that but we didn't and so it
was just because we had a great
um we had we'd like to play together
we're trying to figure out other ways
that we can play
right and and i'm like i am and like i
always thought i want to be fun to teach
because i'm really a frustrated stand-up
comic
and i thought oh then you have like
people who have to come to your class
and then that's like oh mandatory added
and i was
like oh how cool but i had never really
taught before
and i had done workshops or whatever but
never a full-on course
and like i wasn't afraid to say yes i'm
like oh propose a
university course to be you that's where
we started
um and i'm like oh and so it's like
holding your breath
holding your breath and saying yeah i'll
do that even though i've never done it
before
oh write a syllabus how the heck do you
do that
you know just and and you do a lot of
what's called well
i in in in the art world it's called
inspiration
but between you and i we just steal we
steal each other's stuff right
we steal it but then we remake it and
it's really we are inspired but you take
other people's stuff
and then you remake it in a way that
makes a lot more sense for your audience
but you got to start somewhere start
with some kind of a framework
and that's okay you can you can do that
all right it's legal that is legal that
is okay
and encouraged um i'm really delighted
with this i want to congratulate you
both for your successes and
thank you so much for your generosity in
sharing your insights